I wanted to start with talking about modeling and,
uh,
there are lots of beautiful people on the,
on this planet and there are many people who go into modeling and they're very,
very few who get to where you are.
And it strikes me that there are some,
it would seem success cases of,
uh,
in this case,
women who have gone off to build incredible businesses like Kathy Ireland.
And there are others.
So,
wanted to start with asking you if you had,
when you were getting started or even now,
any role models among women who,
or men who have,
have gone from modeling to do other things.
I mean,
you,
you certainly mentioned one,
Kathy Ireland.
Um,
there's a long list,
you know,
Cindy Crawford,
Christy Turlington,
just allow many women who are in the industry and have used their platform or
voice or,
or experiences,
uh,
to build businesses or to make meaningful impact in the world in whatever way
they're passionate about.
And like for me,
that is,
that is success.
And,
and I,
I dunno,
yeah,
I did not anticipate working in fashion or being a model,
but I recognize somewhere along the line that there's so much more you can do
with it.
And the women who have come before me,
uh,
certainly have proved that
it's,
it seems like from the outside looking in that much like say entertainment,
uh,
the machinery of fashion and beauty and so on probably has a lot of casualties.
Meaning it just chews up and spits out a lot of people.
There's really high,
it would seem to be turnover.
A lot of turnover.
Yeah.
What were some of the key decisions that you and,
or your family or people like managers made that helped you to navigate,
to avoid some of the most common pitfalls?
Maybe you could just start with like what are some of the most common mistakes
and pitfalls?
Sure.
I mean,
honestly,
Tim,
I feel like I'm living my own version of a Cinderella story or an American
dream.
I mean,
I have been able to travel the world and have been able to learn from the most
extraordinary people.
I'm sitting here with you talking,
I mean,
this is,
I feel like I'm,
I'm living a dream every day and,
and you know,
I certainly did not anticipate going into fashion or being a model.
I,
I had a very different kind of career path in mind and I had this opportunity
and I,
and I took it.
Yeah,
that was the,
what was the opportunity?
So I was,
so you grew up in the Midwest?
I grew up in the Midwest and my father's a doctor.
He's an emergency room physician,
one of the most hardworking people you'll ever meet.
And so selfless.
And I have three sisters and my mom's an artist,
so I just like grew up in this amazing Midwestern picturesque kind of childhood.
And at 13 I was stopped in a mall and asked if I would be interested in walking
in a fashion show at the time.
Not only did I not care about,
uh,
it was,
it just wasn't my life.
Fashion.
I mean,
I didn't even subscribe to magazines.
I,
I was focusing on school.
I was focusing on ballet,
academics and sports and,
and so anyway,
this idea of modeling was like totally not even in my,
in my,
um,
in my mind.
And so I didn't,
I didn't enter this,
uh,
with the ambition of building a career in modeling.
I was stopped in a mall at 13,
walked in a local charity fashion show to raise money for a local family who's
my friend's father.
Her had,
her dad had cancer.
So it was this charity benefit.
And I was,
I was,
there were scouts there from real agencies and they took my name and said,
let's stay in touch.
I grew a couple inches.
Fast forward to when I'm 15 and I 15.
Oh my God,
Tim.
I was 15 years old and five 11.
It's painful being,
look,
I believe in you.
I've really been,
you know.
Um,
and so anyway,
he said,
I was 15 years old and I got this opportunity to go to New York for the weekend
and,
uh,
meet the designers of cast of Calvin Klein.
And,
and they booked me and I walked in their fashion show and it completely kind of
put me on the map as a new up and coming model.
And I,
and it just was,
it's been a wild ride ever since.
Ever since that,
that day in the mall when I was,
um,
stopped.